zwischen dem 15 dezember und dem 6
januar werden bei apotheken in
deutschland drei kostenlose ffp zwei
masken ausgegeben allerdings zunächst
nur für menschen aus corona
risikogruppen also über 60-jährige und
menschen mit chronischen vorerkrankungen
bild reporter haben in ganz deutschland
nachgefragt wie stark der ansturm auf
die kostenlosen masken in apotheken
bisher war von fünf apotheken in hamburg
hatten nur zwei tatsächlich masken da
einmal gab es die zertifizierten ffp
zwei masken ein anderer inhaber hat
gesagt er gibt alles aus wasser bekommt
und genau das kritisieren viele
apotheker sie haben nämlich die
zertifizierten massen bestellt und
warten nun darauf in einigen apotheken
gibt es nämlich einfach bisher keine
masken wir haben uns in der leipziger
innenstadt in vier verschiedenen
apotheken umgesehen in einer waren keine
masken mehr vorrätig in den anderen drei
waren es die richtigen ffp zwei masken
also kann man bedenkenlos sich seine
gratis maske abholen
hierbei der roten apotheke in der nähe
von marienplatz gekauft und die akten
hier ganz genau drauf das ist die cma
hat tatsächlich ist es so dass in der
münchner innenstadt
bisher alle die wir so sorgsam darauf
achten die in der damberg apotheke in
hamm lief es ganz reibungslos ich bin
rein gekommen habe mich als
risikopatient zu erkennen gegeben der
apotheke hat mir dann nach einer kurzen
beratung diese masken hier ausgehändigt
das sind effekte zwei masken aus
deutschland drei stück an der zahl
ich musste eine kurz formular ausfüllen
und dann konnte ich schon wieder gehen
und hatte die drei masken dabei wir
waren jetzt den ganzen tag in mannheim
unterwegs in sämtlichen apotheken als in
zwölf stück an der zahl haben
festgestellt dass die apotheke hier nur
zertifizierte masken verkaufen und
vertrauensbonus die in der verbraucher
einfach hat und den er auch ruhig nutzen
sollen
denn ich war die erkrankung bringt ihr
genug ängste und sorgen mit sich
sorgen hat einigen apotheken auch der
große andrang auf die kostenlosen masken
bereitet er lief nicht überall gleich ab
aber wie groß war der ansturm auf die
apotheken sehr groß und sehr groß also
die anforderungen im vergleich zu
normalen zeiten sind circa zwei bis drei
prozent höher
katastrophal hat natürlich leider gottes
aufgrund der der zügigkeit der ganzen
sache hat mir natürlich wir haben uns
zwar bemühte zu bekommen aber auch die
lieferanten konnte eine liefer das hängt
hier stehen nicht allein auf einer insel
sondern man sieht ja von den zulieferern
abhängig und das hatte die alle zu
schnell geklappt aber gut einen tag
später war es dann eigentlich im griff
im moment ist unser lagerbestand sehr
gut wir bekommen gerade täglich ware
aber sie ist zwölf ich nach zwei drei
stunden auch schon wieder raus wir
bekommen dann in den folgetagen reader
ware und ich glaube so wie wir hat jede
apotheke ausreichend besteht deshalb der
appell an die bevölkerung lassen sie
sich zeit stellen sie sich nicht nehmen
die schlangen an besuchen sie uns auch
zwischen weihnachten und neujahr nicht
unbedingt an heiligabend und silvester
aber bis zum 6 januar läuft die aktion
und jeder bekommt seine drei rates
masken
wir gehen davon aus dass bis weihnachten
jede unserer apotheken 5000
die zwei masken abgegeben hat 27
millionen bürger innen in der
bundesrepublik sind dann versorgt wurden
mit jeweils drei masken
das sind dann fast 90 millionen masken
lila von zehn tagen über die
öffentlichen apotheken bedarfsgerecht
verteilt wurden die apotheker müsse
zunächst in vorkasse gehen bevor sie das
geld für die ausgegebenen masken von der
bundesregierung zurück bekommen kosten
pro maske rund fünf euro
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dir das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren